[Music] what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation it is time for the Gen V almost
almost the point for the Gen said it again gen V
Episode 2 today if you didn't catch our reaction
episode one that is up here on the channel
thank you guys so much for being here John
how are you I am generating lots of excitement
G it's getting better Coy I'm generally thrilled
to be this vivacious ly intact oh my God how
vicarious of you ladies and gentlemen be sure
to leave a like on this video that'd be very
much appreciated be sure to subscribe click
that notification we get notifi when reaction
where episode 3 is up here on the channel I
also want to say thank you to all who have been
buying RR apparel www. reation shop.com got my
sister to be the head designer for us we have
this shirt who influences the influencers I
feel like that's geny appropriate we also got
this t-shirt that t-shirt this new one that
we launched this week for them Star Wars funds
and another one and then we got a whole bunch
more it's one of the best ways to support the
channel thank you guys so very much especially
for videos like this which are likely to be
demonetized due to what the content is happen
with all of our episodes of the boy season 3
lastly full length 3 and watch along sing with
your own copy of gen V available for super sexy
rejects over our patreon page cover several shows
exclusively over there reaction highlights and
watch alongs included let's get into it ladies and
gentlemen [Music] but I'm a looky L we're looking
right now black noir Breaking
Bad I mean yeah nice Metallica
flip I think this show has a little bit
more of a sadness to it too there's a
lot of Sorrow it's not gleefully malicious
it's sadly malicious yeah the kids are sad
man like there's a permeating sense
of loneliness that's always there
God dang it's night time how long they been
cleaning this up I mean that's a big mess I
have $5 million worth of Golden Boy merch hey
Golden Boy suffered a full psychotic break was
also a chronic drug user thank God Andre Anderson
was there to stop him classic superhero story
of course A Psycho Killer but Heroes rise look
for the helpers all that [__] and we're also
throwing together a Brink Memorial Galla should be
a nice little Le fine they're the one who actually
fought Golden Boy Oh a bender Asian with pronouny
great idea Kyle try selling that to Dallas in Fort
Lauderdale oh boy this feels like necessary
viewing to complete your boy experience yeah
I immediately take away one of my points last
episode if the wood is exposed we all have
a big potentially fatal problem when 400
kids learned they weren't gifts from God
but their parents drugged them with compound V
infants I barely had any did I wow you had one
tonight good stats excellent barely also good
point Ashley you okay I wasn't totally sure
what you're into so I packed the bong she's
not used to being even comforted like that
or for someone forgiving her I am with you you
pick any of it a should we do all of it yes I
promised myself I'd keep my head down work my
ass off no room for anything else man she was
at school for 24 hours it's first day tomorrow
it's not even the first day orientation time
damn I wondering if had shown into classes
but nope can I get a selfie uh no jeez up my
friend Marie Moro say what's up who are you
shs I'm live here top 10 top 10 what I mean
you don't have your push notifications turned
on I don't have a phone okay Nolan yeah the
first freshman ever to be ranked in the top 10
yo damn this is like college football I am Jose
Mourinho his death is paying off this
is conflicting five the attention you
can get off of the death of a loved one
it really just how do you make it about
you that CL ultimate clout Chase tell you
I created this channel I'm just waiting for
it one of you one of us that's why you
grew out so many of us be right back I
already have the thumbnail way more reject
lose ready to launch you seen that Scream
[Music] movie CH he's got the right
idea she got the right idea influencers
they're the best yeah the Real Enemy
I'm sorry I know what Brink meant
to you I don't know why Luke did
it red hat good guy something funny
Rufus Rufus no no dumb [__] was it
about Golden Boy I want to hear I said
what some guys will do just to get away
from Kate ouch buy yourself a nice Lille
Slugger and swing that bat as hard as you
can into your nuts every hour on the hour
and every time you swing jamanji [Laughter]
my soul sister sorry I me no disrespect to you
your community I'm Jeff is his name crutches
director you are not easy to get a hold of no I'm
sorry about the crutches tripped on the red carpet
at paleyfest this is for you haly Center why is
this happening rankings are based on a careful
analysis of talent skill brand awareness and
social mention you [__] own Twitter right now #
black magic no this show needs to be updated it's
called X that's right formerly Twitter ad First
National interview had to rescue Master boox 20
from that nut job allow to Los it before my first
national interview and here you are I want to push
you around Big Year Smashbox 20 huge Luke gave us
what got you here look after your mother died I
wanted to crawl into a bottle of Mallen and stay
there but we push through no matter how hard it
gets you're going to be a better polarity than I
ever was is this an actual wholesome relationship
with a parent I don't trust it wholesome
disregards one person's death I have an interview
yeah one-onone with Haley Miller Jeff didn't
tell you hay Miller's going to ask me questions
everybody cannot wait to hear from you and Andre
you guys are heroes So currently we're testing
the guardians of gulan guardians volume one it's
just all written out you got to memorize your
little brain you got it isn't this the [Music]
life a take the stage I want to see these
characters descent well it seems like every
time she levels up it comes with great traumas
and I will still take the photo that's why you
say yes to give the illusion of choice did you
get that from your dad did l say something to
you about my dad he just said the woods before
he died he said uh your dad has it oh don't
understand how the most sane person that I have
ever met just loses his [__] and I'm the only
one curious about it well good luck with that I
am not curious he tried to kill me that [__]
at the club Brink was going to expel me for
it did you know that no I would never ask for
anything you don't have to you have your dad
and half the school ready to cover for for you
yeah you're way better off right now than me I'm
sorry your friend is dead and I'm sorry Brink is
dead but leave me out of it interesting Dynamics
what a great monologue cuz that's what a tricky
Arc I just want everyone here to know that I
know we all experience a great our director
man teaching theater class welcome to acting for
auditions yes acting for self tapes coming next
week with a prepared scene because I want to see
what kind of Cl yes I'll be with what did that
mean it's the real the sniff that got me it was
the sniff it's just really savoring the moment M
hey suest right ug sorry dude Liam you piece of
[__] let me guess you made this poor girl get
small cuz that's the only way your looks big what
that's exactly what happened that dude he bangs
everyone to compensate for his tiny thimble I
should have warned you I'm sorry anyways want
to be partners up now I'm so worried for her
the system is going to eat Emma no she's guys
if there's anything you know about this world
people who deserve to end off well definitely
good there Professor brinkhof died the same way
he taught a hero nobody could possibly replace
him so I will all right but we'll also get into
the intersection of superpowers and mental health
which so she got into the class yes sorry I'm
late I'm Dean Shetty it's a pleasure to meet you
likewise we're letting Miss Moro audit the junior
year classes what you and Andre did it's obvious
you belong here I've been saying so villainous it
ever occur to you while you're getting it and I'm
not cuz Bender doesn't play in Jacksonville
you rejected me from this school I don't owe
you or anyone anything everyone just needs to
leave me the F alone whoa nope you're getting
interviewed by Miller right just tell her the
truth about what I did that's all they gave me
a script slipping in go off script whatever story
you tell them they have to run with that's what
Brink always said it's a nice detail with the
Dual necklace yeah noticed that for the first
time the chain in the pearls as a congresswoman
from Brooklyn after brutally murdering an innocent
protest homelander woo parents of Luke rean better
known as Golden Boy barricaded themselves inside
their home now their attorney says they're
simply in mourning but then why are they
hiding what do you think he'd do he wouldn't
stop till he about to the bottom of it let's
go a montage where's that guy with the
baseball bat and whacking his nuts he's
yanji once say now it's about time there
he was good call did you think I picked
you cuz you get tiny M no no I picked you
cuz you're great cuz I want to learn from
you uh but me you kind of want to see
her get tiny a little bit it's like when
you hang out with an adult actress you
kind of want to see their video you're
curious no way I'm typ casting you unless you
like getting small I'm always small that's my
secret cat small heart can never get big hurts I
mean I'm losing the name on the back of my teeth
what do you mean sorry nothing I'm just okay no
you want to let her in I love the relationships
cuz she's actually interesting and not just like
surface they could have made the popular girl that
I purge to get small like yeah you're not getting
small for this scene who do you want to play Queen
mave then you're playing Queen mave my muse D
hope she doesn't betray her before I was a dean
I was a behavioral psychologist specializing
in superheroes it's difficult for you you to
open up because when you lose control tragedy
your mama dad which wasn't your fault wow you
are a professional you clamp up and you push
everyone away how I doing am I warm I cold I'm
not here to do keg stands or get high or get
in touch with my feelings about my past your
tears are not giving it away oh know why do you
want to be a hero to help people and the view
from Seven Tower doesn't hurt because you view
yourself as a villain why really my sister she
got adopted I don't know where maybe with enough
money I can I can find her uh she'll see that I'm
not a monster MH we could be a family again get
your validation from your sister if she accepts
you then but you need to have self-acceptance
man I like you Marie I just want to help you
what a hot ass Dean SL psychologist you guys see
my therapist whoa I would tottally my therapist
go just distractingly hot can we all get a session
going I go to therapy every day now be so healed a
sorry guys can't make it got therapy I mean I get
it Paul I'm Greg that's my day whoa every refen
is in there this Cameo oh my easy Sam every
time you try to leave you hurt yourself sure
[Music]
spinal tap whoa
dude where is all this stuff they cleared it out
is that what they did not here no it's all just
here but invisible it smells like bleaching here
why would they do that the is going on I don't
know but we should stop asking immediately
oh that's how she betrayed oh that is cruel
wow dude immed like star of Fun Size with Little
Cricket has to throw up to get tiny wow patriarchy
makes women Chase unattainable beauty standards
and I for one am [__] sick a fainting help oh
dude what if you lit your tail oh naughty sexy
like it's a is this an only fans mhm yeah baby
Nancy ring that [__] but the patriarch is
really forcing some [__] you know why would
you do that Nancy re was it a secret of course it
was a [__] secret sorry but you never said that
I just I thought you had an experience that
could help other girls wow security cameras
melted did you do that no I know something
High did your dad has it this this security
it's a clue but I think he hit something in
here oh that's good that he spok in Clues H
the riddle really helped not had to say was Statue
dad statue it's hidden in this Cod piece check the
d of that's how you know if Spider-Man's real
or not you got to check the shading see iPhone
16 if you're watching this okay I know this
sounds crazy but they have my brother he's
not de he's underneath the scop they call
it the woods it's like this up hospital or
something oh no Brink is a part of this I'm
going to go in there right now I'm going to
make him give me my brother back if you're
seeing this I guess things got pretty Fu
and then some schizophrenia or some [__] right
he died in that facility that um some something
Grove unless he didn't that sounds insane right
oh [__] interview um go I got to get a few
hours sleep anyway my head kills from all the
pushing up and doing lately no I I should stay
because we need to figure out everything that
we can about seriously it's not just your dad
I don't get how you guys can push all that
to the side right now what you just learned
yeah they both have super compartmentalization
just us we knew we had to stop Golden Boy
before he killed more innocent people
oh that's mean that's just not true what
about London's character is she gonna
do you think she vouches is she going
to do her own thing Ah that's what I was
wondering if she was going to say Jordan
Lee careful Jordan's the one who really
Golden Boy can you trust the MUA right
now please don't die to
this episode yeah I like you
Woods hey such organization on
these folders make Woods great again
who hey he's he's that boy
screenshot there you go Boogie oh
my oh no no no no that the computer damn you
got here just in time boy Marie Haley Miller
oh wow hey she looks like a fox person oh
no will this be a commentary of some kind
doubted it though Co what don't worry there's
not going to be any gotas we won't mention your
sister wow oh what do you mean I thought you
knew I'm sorry we invited her to comment wow
you know where she is not really we just found
an email can I have it what did annab Beth say
she said she didn't want anything to do with
you this is great great information to learn
before getting interviewed seconds before in a
murderous frenzy charging and it was just you I
mean this should be more motiv just do whatever
you want yeah that's what I'm thinking she's
going to just go for the seven don't cut away
from her face she's either going to crash and
burn or become the black Starlight oh boy yeah
exactly they show knew what they were doing I
knew I had to stop Golden Boy there it is before
he killed more innocent people yes Jordan give
in damn it you find that kind of Courage I
love it you're watching the development of
how they become this we're seeing the origin of
characters we hadn't met yet but care about like
the seven God I haven't been so flushed in a
scene like this in a while I just is London
gonna come the villain though like does Jordan
oh man just ask for another interview just go
back vodka I think she was her roommate oh answer
that sincerely you know what I was focused I mean
we're all roommates with VOD coy some of us
have some rough years John clearly you still
are oh
[Music] man everyone feeling small
biman cutting parallel with powers
is like so depraved sad did you know
about my sister of course not come
here this is how you take control yes use
her how do hug her eyes open that's what
I'm talking about you know what doing you know
what you're doing no no no the strings rise no
her your product fought now I'm there's a lot
you can learn from [Laughter] VA what's going
on can I help you all good campus security
nothing to worry about campus SWAT oh dude
why I wouldn't go that way yeah dude
[Music] no oh Sinister DS have a
wider range of hearing than us like
dogs turn it off Bob first you're going to get
this flashlight nice and wet with youring mouth
then I'm going to stuff it right up your tight
little Chocolate Starfish woo until you see God
until you see the hot dog water you want to
[__] give this flly oh my this this is the
beginning of A Beautiful [Applause] [Laughter]
Romance I'm totally oh the kids are not all right
k k so this is a very good show yeah it is yeah
this thing go hard yeah man that was really good
yeah so soothing so comforting I'm on side guys
yeah no no no no I think [Music] um they created
them so the property they own them um and pressure
you know creates diamonds saying you want compound
that country you got to embrace capitalism you
got to lean in just get stronger or else you can
complain about it or we can use your complaints
to just make more money where are those bootstraps
you're pulling up from come on you know get after
it it's like the boys great commentary for a show
that Amazon gets to greatly profit from guys oh
they win because they're like they can just punch
whoever they're just punching and profitting just
punching you want to make fun of this the writers
really win the strike come on they fought for what
0.008% income who gets the other 90% of profit off
of us see this commentary Bezos that's what I'm
talking about who's demonetizing this video a
big Corporation one of the biggest in fact John
what' you think I am gripped continually by the
series it's yeah this fascinating blend of you
know all the shock and schlock that you're used
to from the boys but yeah as you guys have both
pointed out with a greater sense of melancholy
being lost in this world and and being point that
out caught up in yeah just these systems that feel
so much bigger than and they're really great at
like even though the boys also has that in that
you know you think you're oh you're part of the
seven you've made it you know you're going to be
a big fish in a small pond or whatever you know
this feels exponentially more you know Koi pond
uh yeah and just yeah the the messiness of the
choices I think is really compelling maddening at
times but in a good way in a dramatic way and uh
and yeah I it's hard to watch a show like this in
some aspects because you sit here and you endear
toward characters and and it it's always a sign of
something that's working when it breaks your heart
when people you know make the wrong choice go with
the selfish option or you know cover something up
when they should just be vulnerable about it and
to watch as you know all these Predators desend
upon these poor kids you know who are just trying
to do right and find their lot in the world uh
yeah I'm quite compelled what did you guys think
sure Coy has like a minute of thoughts why you
take it away Coy with your your brevity what I'm
known for uh I really love how the characters
that have had like the least amount of screen
time keep pulling me towards them uh like the the
character played by London Thor the Jordan Lee I
think the name was um I'm so curious whether they
become a villain whether they like find some sort
of Justice whether they like get to actualize
or not and I really like that the show is able
to juggle like eight leads and I'm still curious
about people that have only had a few minutes of
screen time and I think that's really great world
building because it'd be easy for a show to give
you a seven and to give you a certain amount
of leads and the first episode The or uh but
this one uh I you know I didn't expect to lose
the lead Golden Boy literally The Golden Boy in
the first episode and I really didn't expect this
to take so many turns to bolster not even the the
characters we've had at like tier two but like
the three and four every time we cut to one of
those characters I'm so curious and the way it's
building out the world isn't just improving on the
boys but it's actually improving on this show in
real time like the idea of you mentioned like the
origin of someone that would be susceptible to the
seven like it's building out that world again the
all really I'm we're going to point out what Greg
said I'm we're going to pretend it's all right and
I'm going not even extra I'm just going to repeat
it with new words because of my brevity but I like
what do I think Greg Greg when you cleaned up
that dead body no but I I love that uh it's not
only clear but I I mentioned the first episode
it's kind of like punching at everyone's like
worldview and I think that's really important to
have a show that saturies our world from multiple
pronged attacks so the the boys is very good at
attacking politically and capitalism and all those
things but this is coming at like parenting and
Trauma and the way people like abuse therapy and
like the way it's doing drug commentary bulimia
commentary cutting commentary what it's like to
come up in a world that feels so big and this
world is actually big so what I love about
comic books is there at an 11 so if you have a
morality story it feels Larger than Life so it
actually feels more approachable the reason I've
always loved comic books is I've never identified
with religion because I've I personally always
considered religion a fiction just my belief but
with the greatest comic book ever Jesus is such a
superhero for that world but with me seeing it as
fiction I've always liked that these morality
stories I know are written by people to shape
a fiction to improve the world to improve our
morality to make us better but when you make it
so big it feels oddly more approachable because
you're like well if they can do this large than
life thing I can do this thing and this show
is addressing that side of superhero lore where
it's where it's Peter Parker having to overcome
this bully and you know that he's trying to not
use his powers and this is these kids you know
dealing with bulimia and cutting and these things
that so many people deal with and and Trauma and
depression and anxiety and wanting to fit in but
since it's set in a superhero world it's more
approachable than just a cwen show so whereas
the first episode gave me this great world that I
was like oh this is a great Gap show between the
boys and I love these characters I'm impressed
this is almost like this is hitting a different
Target demo a different generation it might bring
them into the boys and it gives us I I joked but
like a year of the boys we get 10 weeks of this
we get you know the other show and the whole time
it's not the same audience it's not the same goal
it's not trying to tell the same story and I you
know people get sick of me talking about Comics
but that's why I love them is there's so many
different versions like when you read The Avengers
that's different than Justice League when you
read Spider-Man it's different than Superman or
Batman because there's so many different ways to
tell that story and this is doing the do you like
Superman or do you like Batman with the boys or do
you like gen V and I'm just so impressed it I it's
great it is a very impressive show it is very very
impressive uh they deal with a lot of sensitive
issues more sensitive I think than what the boys
like like again the boys I think is very is very
clever and here this feels more personal because
it feels more intimate because like when look at
the boys you're cutting around in many different
characters in many different locations where here
this is an mainly an oncampus uh experience a very
intimate experience with these guys who are all in
the same Hub so I love The Ensemble and it really
does shine a light on like especially with that
influencer moment of when they was exposing the
bulimia moment of it of uh and like how people
Fain pain and um and and exploit others in in
a in a way of uh posturing help yeah know like
virtue signaling is a buzzword that's used wrong
but that's virtue signaling like I think it's
great to address that like I I I haven't read the
comments yet on what I said last week but people
like oh K doesn't like when they punch her BL but
I think it's really important to address people
using Progressive ideology as a as a weapon and
I think it's important to show like social justice
being used negatively because it's pandering for
these companies people and I love that they it it
just feels a part of the characters but everyone
has a a new no one has like a villainous turn
where it's just mustache twirling you know even
with the girl when she was caught on her [__]
uh she you know they do stay with her for a little
bit like oh damn I messed up yeah when it's like
whatever you knew what you were doing and even
Golden Boy like we got his yeah exactly yeah you
get that with Golden Boy my one concern like I I
love the idea because I think they wanted you to
kind of think of Starlight like what it was it was
something I was saying in the in the first episode
of like yeah there qualities of her that kind of
remind you of Starlight um but you could still
feel Shad to something different and then here
they even make the comment of like here's where
she becomes black Starlight or not right yeah and
I guess my one concern is the Trope but in my but
but then I'm like oh but it could be a commentary
on how we've been getting like a like a Wanda you
know like a villainous from hero to villain like
here's how you could really do it in a way like I
know you like I really love Wanda and Multiverse
and Madness but I do agree with you on the thing
you've often complained about is that gap of a
transition from W division yeah and here you get
to witness that via the the traumatic experience
Tak advantage of know and I think mean you could
draw some solid Scarlet Witch parallels the red
she was wearing but the way they take are who's
the who's the transgender character the woman's
played by London Thor I went to acting school
with that's why I kept accidentally call and the
character is called Jordan Lee yeah character
Jordan Lee so Jordan Lee and the way they've
introduced Jordan Lee and the way they introduced
even um I forget everyone's name John po polarity
PO is it Andre yeah Andre Anderson right the way
they've introduced Jordan Jordan and Andre at even
at first you're like are they going to be the bad
guys right right and then as the shows progress
ing you're seeing this flip R already within the
second episode where Marie is going down a darker
path and Andre like oh maybe he's actually the
protagonist yeah he sacrificed things and she's
getting more isolated and vengeful yeah and then
Jordan is is someone you're like oh I don't see
Jordan as villainous at all actually when when
they kind of um set them up to be that way in
the first episode so I think the way they play
with expectations versus whatever realities are
unfolding is really well done I think the one
thing semi working against the show right now
and and granted we still got one more episode to
go before because they seemed pretty intentional
whenever they decide to release three I know they
did that for season two was the first time they
did it and and it took it I was like yeah you
need the first three they did that for season
three when I didn't feel like they needed it no
and I think this could have ended here and done
two I think one I honestly I think one was fine
like you could just ended on one um but you are
it's a new property exactly so I think there is a
justification to do three um so before forming an
opinion on it I I'm very casually interested in
the mystery of the woods and stuff I think we've
just had such bigger um you know Mysteries
to unpack via compound V and other things
that we've done where this does feel like the
most te mystery drama thing they are unpacking
the bo river river Wednesday you know there's
definitely some Wednesday the basement it's got
It's got that quality to it where yeah but I like
how it's imbued in the character development of
it and yeah it's not some nefarious clandestine
thing it's about his brother being there it's not
like we heard there's bad guys in the basement
that would be that very cheesy ECW instead it's
like my brother's trapped in the basement caused
my death right now I'm I'm waiting to to see if
if that becomes more compelling I'd say cuz right
now that's weirdly I find everything else super
interesting and that's the one part that we keep
cutting back to that I don't find myself itching
at what's going on there I'm hoping the next
episode puts it because I'm at like a seven
with the mystery and I'm at like a nine and a
half 10 with all the people yeah that's funny
you brought it up and I was like yeah I'm so
invested in just the characters and and this
immediate Journey that like yeah the woods I'm
kind of like is is at the back of my mind yeah
cuz like the guy that was running it's dead the
guy that had affected is dead so it's like I don't
really care about it I want to stay with these
alive people well and you know that there are
things like this lurking and there's going to be
some kind of shadowy truth that's being hit like
we know that about this world now and Brink is
like you know our VA here but I love that VA is
the big overarching eagle evil and I think we're
going to see those things come into play in the
next episode and I honestly think there's going
to be like a cliffhanger maybe bigger than this
that would be why they did three oh yeah you got
to but I I man I I love that this is going to be
weekly cuz people will be talking about but I do
kind of wish it was just Warners yeah I don't feel
like the show is going to pop off right away but
I think like the boys season one I think it has
an opportunity to really I think the word of mouth
on this is going to be phenomenal it's so good and
I mean I know you both were uh trepidacious and
you weren't you know run I wasn't that interested
yeah like it was just like it's fine and and I
was really excited so I love that it exceeded
expectations in two directions where they just put
homelander on the thumbnails for the trailers I I
would have been watching is that not what we're
going to do uh yeah every thumbnail homelander
Easter there were frames of homelander we could
put authentically in this guys we got to be the
enemy that we're watching a commentary on in order
to profit off the enemies that pay for this thing
while we watching on the enemies Network you know
it's part of it you guys the evil that is YouTube
Only extrapolated by the evil that is Amazon that
we were consuming and then putting it on for you
capitalism at play here it's just it trickles
down the Nancy Reagan joke maybe my favorite
joke in the boys history there was a Nancy Reagan
BJ joke that was the perfect it was plot driven
it furthered the narrative it was exactly my kind
of humor and F reaganism I love that I'm so happy
whoa don't bring your wokeness to this w we need
we need to play middle up the aisle we need to
attract cing Show episode one I said something
slightly anti-le so this week I'm coming at re
yes my hero I'm going to change it every week yeah
I'll be like Jordan Lee switching there you go you
heard me yeah all right be fun to edit Greg oh
the the reviews are just uncut no like I I made
a note to mute the there number of words the
letter B so oh really yeah I make mental notes
all the time when we watch things uh all righty
guys I wonder if you'd have to be uncut if you
had like dense skin enough that could be on fire
I wonder if he didn't have an option Golden Boy so
you said it was uncut I wonder could all righty
guys pack that real quick all right could he be
Serv we're gonna we're going to take a little
did Golden Boy have a bris or not we might CH
clothes all right well thank you for being
here we'll see you guys soon y Mark leech
yes Mark oh you're in for it Mark it's time for
a chat GP shout out all right John yes pick some
categories here okay give me your favorite movie
character uh any movie character James Bond James
Bond Perfect all right give me your favorite um
Beach uh Manhattan Manhattan Beach uh who's your
favorite uh movie or TV show Monster um the
Baba Duke I guess the Baba Duke okay uh give
me a the the a year 1957 1957 all all right
give me a um a pronoun uh they all right give
me um a superla uh uh uh stupidest stupidest
give me a uh a superhero weapon um Boomerang
Boomerang okay uh a religion um oh uh how's
about scientology Scientology okay a type of
Transportation skateboard skateboard okay and um
an occupation um uh uh a bodybuilder bodybuilder
all right sweet all right Mark all right Greg's
going to enter the magic words okay all right
um let me just uh oh wait no I can't do that
I gotta retype it okay you can't double copy
I have a YouTube channel All Right Where I Need
to shout out a patron his name is Mark leech yes
we call our patrons super sexy reject write me
a shout out um in under let's say 60 words in
the genre oh hey spice it up yes in the genre of
what what's going be genre uh fantasy romance in
the in the RO in in the in the genre of
a romance but incorporate all of these a
words oh oh I'm so excited here we go here we go
sending sultry thanks to our super sex sexy reject
Mark leech imagine James Bond skateboarding
through 1957 Manhattan with a boomerang en
uh encountering the mysterious babadook Mark
they say it's the stupidest most enchanting
dance of Scientology meets bodybuilder romance
ever witnessed your support is more thrilling
than than a spy mission and for that our hearts
Swoon for you oh my God no human could create
something this good the machine understands
romance Mark does I'm touched right now and
I feel like we've grown closer together just
as a unit you know yeah as a as a polyamorous
relationship I think we're all going to make
it and it's all thanks to chat GPT but more
so thanks to you mark leech thank you for
being here thank you for all of your many
months of unrequited love we'll catch you
soon catch you soon bud bud [Music] bud